tyler valley on the hill for the reds i
think the key for mali is i hope he
didn't go over the scouting report too
much and get psyched out by what the
white sox had done this year i mean they
have annihilated opposing pitching so
that'll bring to the plate guys monty
grandall he is the number two batter
tonight
dive by bottom he will get the out at
first base
this just jams grand all splinters are
flying everywhere and bottle takes the
sure out
so that will bring up jose abreu
swing and a miss got him to chase big
out for mali runner at second two outs
here is eloy jimenez payoff pitch
back-to-back strikeouts for mali fred's
coming up they're going to try and
square up as we used to say instead of
barrel up jonathan stever you see what
he did in his only start he's got the
245 era three and two thirds innings
we've already set the tone that got up
to a bit of a slow start and just like
that he pulled it back together and
retired the last nine batters he faced
nick castiano's he's had a fair amount
of success against the white sox in his
major league career
see you later castellanos puts a charge
into one
upper deck shot
mercy may the reds out to an early lead
if you want to see the definition of a
hanging slider there it is someone
nearly dented a seed up there
one hit off of tyler malley and inning
number one the 1-2 swing gonna miss he
blew a fastball by him tyler malley
strikes out edwin in carnacion and mali
has his third straight strikeout
on the ground going to his left is
garcia up and firing
another fine inning turned in by malik a
leadoff walk to the number eight hitter
who's hitting 217. i think that was just
kind of a mental hiccup for tyler malley
and some words from sanchez to mark
carlson and here's nick madrigal
five strikeouts for tyler malley middle
of the third one-nothing red
jonathan steven working into the third
here he's giving up a couple of hits
barnhart right field and
gone
touch em all tucker second solo home run
off of stever in a two nothing reds lead
he threw a couple of breaking pitches
and you see where grondon wanted that he
wanted it up stever got it in the
wheelhouse and a no two pitcher goes for
a home run here's joey votto he'll bat
with two outs of the bags empty
two-nothing reds third inning
center field
hit well and goodbye baby no 43 miles
per hour off the bat this time
it's a rocket to dead center field
third home run of the game for the rads
in a three-nothing league
back-to-back walk but the home run by
votto seems to have shook him a bit
winker started the season slowly went on
a tear was since cooled off again in
fact he is out as do as you can come
chance to break out of it right here
in the air right center field how about
that for a breakout
way out of here three run home run and
the reds are in
fitness tyler malley he has been good so
far through three he has struck out five
and here comes jose abreu
struck him out second time he struck out
abreu was some action on that pitch
right there that again is that split
finger pitch the one two swing and a
miss he used it there and blew it right
on by edwin carnacion seven strikeouts
over four shutout innings for tyler
mouse
socks of mustered three hits off of
tyler malley through five innings third
time through the lineup
madrigal upstairs to swat it to right
field down the line it goes
madrigal into second base nikki's two
strikes
has a second two-strike hit
and the white sox have loaded the bases
in the sixth with nobody out eloy
jimenez
eloy's bat goes flying it's a drop at
third and out the call at second base
sox do get a run madrigal scores abrayu
out at second on a close play five and
two thirds innings four hits and he will
watch on as he hopes tj antone can get
the reds out of the six once again
they're loaded for luis robert
swing
and a miss
three stranded 6-1 reds
it is the
big league debut for garrett crochet the
first player to bypass the miners after
being drafted since mike leake the 11th
overall pick in the 2020 draft and here
he is in a white sox uniform
100 strike three garrett crochet keep
that baseball his first major league
strikeout
oh two fastball inside get out of here
two down
garrett crochet is carving
contact
to first
yeah we can get used to this
lead off base runner for the reds lotto
stands in
bouncing around and then jumps right
back in
i think he wanted that pitch back
into left center field
and vado
off the wall
akiyama rounding third heading for home
here comes the relay throw to the plate
and it gets away and the reds have
played add-on otto with the rbi double
right-hander sal romano he's got to get
the final three outs of this bowl game
and the white sox down to their final
out tonight and will bring up luis
robert here two outs in the ninth inning
seven to one cincinnati
into right field right at castianos and
that'll do it the reds win their sixth
straight
and it's been a long road back but now
the cincinnati reds back to the 500 mark
as they take game one of this three-game
set against the high-powered chicago
white sox